I want to talk about hate speech as a
kind of poison and that's a metaphor of
course my reason to use this metaphor is
to go back to our a very old by recent
standards piece of hate speech that some
of you might have heard of that was
published by Julius Streicher
Stryker was a publisher in Nazi Germany
who published - Tomer have any of you
heard of - Duma okay the stormer the
daily store mahadesh Norma the current
web site the racist web site the daily
stormer is a a current reincarnation or
sees itself as a current reincarnation
of this weekly sort of newspaper I think
it was weekly there was published by
Ullaeus Stryker and Stryker was involved
not in the official propaganda wing of
the Nazi Party during the Second World
War during that period but he was
involved with unofficial sponsorship
from the Nazi Party and he the - Noma
was immensely popular the another thing
that our striker published was a range
of publications directed at children so
- Tomer wasn't directed at children of
the stormer it was directed at adults
and in fact some people think that it's
mix of sensational stories of Jewish
violence and sent mixed up with
sensational and lurid sexual content was
part of what gave it a big presence in
the culture and people who couldn't
afford copies of - Norma would could
read them on the village on village
noticeboards because they were pinned up
there so it had a very wide readership
they are the poisonous are hate speech
that I'm going to think about though is
a piece called dare gift pills this is
I'm going to move on with your help to
talk about Morgan
versions of hate speech but poison was
the central metaphor of Nazi
anti-semitic propaganda their gift belts
as some of you who know German will know
means the toadstool or the poisonous
mushroom and in this story there's a
picture of a small boy with his mother
walking through a woodland and they are
looking for mushrooms on a nice fine
autumn day like today and as they're
looking through the forest his mother
gives him a warning and says you've got
to look out for those ones the gift
pills the poisonous mushrooms the
poisonous mushrooms look just like the
healthy ones but they are death they are
deadly they will kill you they are death
to our folk and the little voices just
like the Jewish people or something like
this so this is ongoing metaphor between
the poison of of something that looks
completely innocent and healthy and
that's one mention of poison it's part
of the content of a very important bit
of German propaganda to see the Jewish
people as looking normal
but being poisonous like a poisonous
mushroom and one thing to say about that
is not only is it making it them it's
associated with deadliness it's also
making them impossible to trust it's
also making the hate speech impossible
to answer so imagine your child is
learning that their Jewish neighbor is
like a poisonous toad store and the
Jewish neighbor says no I'm not and all
of this goes to prove that you're
exactly the have the innocent appearance
of a toadstool as opposed to a mushroom
so there's a sense in which the the
credibility denial is part of the
message as well as the deadliness and
these sometimes go hand-in-hand
credibility denial which silence is the
possibility of counter protest that's
one of the
things that interest me about certain
kinds of hate speech that they are very
hard to answer because they damage the
credibility of somebody who might want
to fight back so another place that the
metaphor of poison comes up is perhaps
more accurately with the Nuremberg court
trial of Julius Streicher himself his
words were described as poison his words
were described as a poison that had
contaminated and and infected I think
was the word suitably translated
infected the minds of the German people
and turned them against Jews so we had
this metaphor of the Jews as poison and
then of strike his words as themself
poison what happened to striker it might
be shocking to think of now but at the
Nuremberg trials he was hanged after the
Nuremberg trials he was found guilty of
of hate crime through what he had
published and as far as I know this is
the only time I might be wrong I'm not a
historian I'm just a philosopher just a
philosopher I think this might be the
only time that someone got hanged or was
suffered capital punishment for a speech
crime we are so used to the idea that
speech should be protected no matter how
awful in this particular case the speech
was considered so heinous that it
deserved a death penalty I'm not going
to comment on that apart from to say I
don't think the death penalty is
appropriate for anyone that's a
different topic but it is a reminder
about how seriously certain sorts of
hate speech have been taken historically
and it's also worth reminding ourselves
of that in a context where different
countries right now have very different
perspectives on hate speech so to turn
to that one important picture of hate
speech and this applies to - drama is he
is as a kind of propaganda
in this case the propaganda is
propaganda that makes somebody seem
inferior or dangerous or not credible
various things that can be can go wrong
with it I'm not offering this as a
definition of hate speech I'm saying
it's something that hate speech very
often tends to do and that idea of hate
speech has a certain kind of propaganda
is embedded in the UN Convention on on
for the eradication of of hey hates the
69 convention is that what I'm thinking
of
anyway I'll read it to you this is the
UN's condemnation of hate speech it's in
light of this convention by the way that
we have hate speech laws
so does Germany so does France many
Western democracies do but not the
United States for reasons that we can
discuss here's the UN State Parties
condemn all propaganda and all
organizations which are based on ideas
of theories of superiority of one race
or group of persons or one color of or
ethnic origin which attempt to justify
or promote racial hatred and
discrimination in any form and undertake
to adopt immediately positive measures
designed to eradicate all incitement to
or acts of such discrimination shall
declare an offense punishable by law all
dissemination of ideas based on racial
superiority or hatred incitement to
racial discrimination as well as all
acts of violence or incitement to such
acts against any race or group a person
of another color or ethnic origin and
also the provision of any assistance to
racist activities so that is what the UN
Convention says to which are most
Western democracies excluding the United
States have signed up that's why we have
laws against incitement to racial hatred
and France and Germany have laws against
Holocaust denial and and so that's the
that's the part of the legal backdrop
and so it's worth mentioning the
historic origins of the concerns about
hate speech before we go on to
discuss it now so I said that one idea
about hate speech which is there in what
I just read instead of hate speech as
propaganda also by the way hate speech
does in citement that was implicit in
that I can say a bit more about that in
a second a different idea about hate
speech is the idea of words that wound I
take that title words that wound from a
very famous piece of work by some
philosophers legal theorists and
critical race series which discusses
hate speech as a kind of assault it is
it draws on American fighting words
doctrine and American doctrine about
assault and says that certain sorts of
hate speech are like a physical assault
on someone so there you can see what's
going on is not Oh is someone reading
some propaganda and getting false or
damaging views about that other group
instead what's happening is these words
are being used directly against the
target as a kind of attack so I'm
talking here about two rolls of hate
speech it can be an attack or it can be
propaganda for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you